in this sprouts teaching technique we
introduce cold call a simple question
method teachers can use to increase
attention boost energy and get a better
understanding of their students teachers
often raise a question and pick the
first hand that goes up likely that's a
good and motivated student sitting in
the first row already knowing the answer
the student who is less eager and less
likely to know the answer is dozing off
in the back and that's a problem with
cold call the teacher randomly names a
student to give the answer J name some
ideal conditions for growing rice the
benefit for the students is that
everybody gets a shot and since no
student would know who is next
they all have to pay attention this
gives shy students more voice increases
the energy level and creates a feeling
of fellowship as all students are
equally treated the teachers also
benefit first it's more fun because
everybody feels more engaged second it's
fast as he or she doesn't need to wait
for hands to go up third the teacher
gets a better understanding of who
already mastered a concept or who needs
more help when you introduce cold call
we recommend using simple questions to
get students on board once they are
prepared the level can raise in a more
advanced form teachers can use cold call
to moderate a discussion if J got the
answer only half right the teacher could
go on and say Sonia give J a hint about
the whether rice seeds seemed to like
then the teacher turns back to J to give
him another shot to get it completely
right
please use the comment section below to
let us know what you think if you are a
student tell us if your teacher uses
cold call if you are a teacher share
with us how you apply it in class and if
it works for you we're releasing updates
regularly so don't forget to subscribe
to our Channel
thank you for watching